الترسانه النوويه الصينيه بين الحقيقه
والتقديرات الامريكيه هل العالم على اعتاب
نظام نووي ثلاثي القطبيه بعد التقارير
الامريكيه التي تصف بالجين باكبر تحدي
عسكري تواجهه يحضر البنتاجون من وتيره
تطور الترسانه النوويه
الاخير لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه امكانيه
بلوغ المخصون النووي الصيني نحو 2500 راس
النووي بحلول 2035 مضيفا ان المخزون
الحالي تخطى 400 راس ذكر التقرير باختبار
135 صاروخا قادرا على حمل رؤوس النووي
خلال عام 2021
كله تحديث في الجيش الصيني يحدث ازمه لدى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تخفي
انزعاجها من التقدم الكبير لسلاح الجو
وتغشى التحاقه سريعا بالقوات الجويه
دفعت الصين عن سياستها بنفي الاتهامات
لامريكيه لها بالرغبه في دخول سباق التسلح
وقال المتحدث باسم خارجيتها جولي جان ان
السياسه بلاده للدفاع عن النفس مؤكدا
الالتزامها بعقيدتها العسكريه التي تنص
العدم البدء باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه بعد
ثلاثه عقود من تلاش الكابوس النووي للحرب
البارده تزداد مخاوف وعشره المتبوعه
بتحذيرات من سعيدين الى امتلاك قوه
النوويه عظمى حتى وان تحقق السيناريو
الاخير للبنت تبقى الصين بعيده عن منافسه
القوه النوويه الامريكيه فالسند الى تقرير
الوزاره التعليم الذي تضع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بلغ المخزون النووي الامريكي
عام 2020 اكثر من ثلاثه الاف و700 راس
النووي مفعل او غير مفعل وهذا العدد هو
الادنى منذ بلغ مخصومها ذروته في اوجه حرب
البارده عام
1967 عندما كان اكثر من واحد وثلاثين الف
راس حربي
الاستراتيجيه الصينيه لبناء جيش عالمي
بحلول عام
201940 هي بالنظر واشنطن مقدمه لسباق نحو
التسلل ثلاثي القطبيه سباق كان على مدى
ثلاثه 73 عاما حكرا على روسيا والولايات
المتحده اعلانهم بانها ستول اهتمام خاصه
ببناء بنيه تحتيه ترتبط بقوتها النوويه
اوكرانيا يضاعف من مخاوف واشنطن التقليديه
والجديده الترسانه النوويه الص المحتمله
وفق تقارير البنتاجون اليست ورقه ضغط
مرتبطه بسياسه بيجين في المحيطين الهندي
والهادي